The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Last lecture, I
did a fairly standard treatment
of the harmonic
oscillator, which is not
supposed to make you
excited, but just
to see that you can do this.
And the path to the
solution was to define
dimensionless
position coordinate,
and then you get a dimensionless
Schrodinger equation.
And the solution of
that involves two steps.
One is to insist that the
solutions to the Schrodinger
equation have an
exponentially damped form.
And then the
Schrodinger equation
is transformed into a new
equation called the Hermite
equation.
You shouldn't get all excited
about that-- the mathematicians
take care of it.
And so the solutions to this
Hermite differential equation
gives you a set of orthogonal
and normalized wave functions.
They give you the energy levels
expressed as a quantum number
plus 1/2, times constant.
The energy levels with
the quantum number v
are even or odd in v, and
they're even or odd in psi.
Even v corresponds to even psi.
V is the number
of internal nodes,
and there are all sorts of
things you can do to say,
well, I expect if I know
how to do certain things
in classical
mechanics, they're are
going to come out pretty
much the same way in quantum
mechanics.
So that's the
standard structure,
but more importantly, I want
you to have in your head
the pictures of the wave
functions, the idea that there
is a zero point energy, and
that there's a reason for that--
that the wave functions
have tails extending out
into the non-classical, or the
classically forbidden region.
And this turns out to be
the beginning of tunneling.
You'll be looking at
tunneling more specifically.
I also want you to know how
the spacing of nodes is,
and that involves generalization
of the bright idea
that the wavelength is h over p.
But if the potential
is not constant,
then p is a function of x.
This is not the quantum
mechanical operator,
this is a function
which provides you
with a lot of intuition.
And then if you know where
the node spacings are, and you
know the shape of
the envelope, you
have basically
everything you need
to have a classical
sense of what's going on.
And then-- I guess it's
supposed to be hidden--
I did a little bit of
semiclassical theory,
and I showed that if you
integrate from the left turning
point to the right
turning point at a given
energy of this
momentum function,
you get h over 2 times
the number of nodes.
And this is the
semiclassical quantization--
it's incredibly
important, and it's
useful either as an exact
or approximate result
for all one-dimensional
problems.
And so it tells
you how to begin.
Now, before I start
talking about what
we're going to do today, I want
to stress where we're going.
So we're going to be looking at
some exactly solved problems.
And so we have a particle in a
box, the harmonic oscillator,
the hydrogen atoms--
you have to count them--
and the rigid rotor.
Now, all of these problems
have an infinite number
eigenfunctions, an infinite
number of energy levels,
and that's intimidating,
but it's true.
Now, these infinite
number of functions
are explicit functions
of the quantum number.
And so we have an
infinite number,
but in order to
describe systems,
we're going to be
calculating integrals.
We're going to be calculating
a lot of integrals
between these infinite
number of functions.
So we have an infinity
squared of integrals.
Well, that shouldn't
scare you because what
I'm going to show you is that
all of the integrals that we
are going to encounter
are explicit functions
of the quantum
numbers, and they have
relatively selection rules.
In other words, which
integrals are non-zero
based on the
difference in quantum
numbers between the left-hand
side and the right-hand side?
So we're collecting
these things in order
to calculate a whole
bunch of stuff.
Now, I told you that
this is a course for use
rather than
philosophy or history.
And so if you encounter any
quantum mechanical problem,
you'd like to be
able to describe
what you could observe with it.
And so if you're armed with
the infinite number of energy
levels and eigen
solutions for our problem,
you can calculate any property.
So you define some property
you're interested in--
there is a quantum
mechanical operator that
corresponds to that property.
And in order to be able
to describe observations
of that property,
you need to calculate
integrals of that operator.
Well, la dee dah.
That should be
intimidating, but it's not
because almost all
of these integrals
can be expressed as a
simple constant times
a function of the
quantum numbers
or the difference
of quantum numbers,
and that's a fantastic thing.
So we have any operator--
suppose the Hamiltonian is
an exactly solved problem
plus something else,
which we'll call h1.
And this is a
complexity in the--
or it's the reality
in the problem.
And in order to deal
with this, again, you're
going to need to calculate
integrals of this operator.
And the last thing that's
really going to be exciting
is once we look at the time
dependent Schrodinger equation,
we're going to get wave packets.
And these are functions
of position and time,
and these wave packets are
classical-like, localized
objects that move following
the Newton's equations
of motion with the center
of the wave packet.
And again, there
are a whole bunch
of integrals you're
going to need in order
to do these things.
And so right now, we're
starting with the best problem
for these integrals, because
a harmonic oscillator
has some special properties.
And the lecture notes
are incredibly tedious,
and they're mostly proofs.
And I'm going to try to go
fast over the tedious stuff,
and give you the
important ideas,
but since there is
some important logic,
you should really
look at these notes.
So what we're going
to be doing today
is we start with the
coordinate momentum operators,
we're going to get
these operators
in dimensionless
form, and then we're
going to get these
a and a-dagger guys.
So this step is
reminiscent of what
I did at the beginning
of the previous lecture,
and then this is magic
because this magic enables
you to just look at
integrals and say,
I know that integral is zero,
or I know that area is not zero.
And with a little
bit more effort--
maybe something that you'd
put on the back of a postage
stamp--
you can evaluate that integral,
not by knowing integral tables,
but by knowing the properties
of these simple little a
and a-dagger.
And that's a fantastic thing.
And it's so fantastic
that this is
one of the reasons why almost
all problems in quantum
mechanics start with a harmonic
oscillator approximation,
because there is so much you
can do with this a and a-dagger
formalism.
Now, at the beginning
I also told you
that in quantum mechanics,
the important thing that
contains everything we're
allowed to know about a system
is the wave function.
But I also told you we can
never measure the wave function.
We can never experimentally
determine it,
and so we need to be able
to calculate what this wave
function does as far
as what we can observe,
and these a's and a-daggers
are really important in being
able to do that.
So I'm going to
start with covering
what I did in the notes, but I'm
going to jump to final results
at some point--
governed by the clock.
And so the first thing
we're going to do is these.
And so what we do is we
define the relationship
between the ordinary
position coordinate.
And this little twiddle
means it's dimensionless,
and so we can write
the inverse of that.
And that's the one we
are going to want to--
well, actually, we go both ways.
And we do the same
thing for the momentum--
p is equal to h-bar
mu omega square
root, p twiddle and the inverse
which I don't need to write.
And finally, we get
the Hamiltonian,
which is p squared over
2 mu plus 1/2 kx squared.
And we'll put that
into these new units.
So we have h-bar mu omega
over 2 mu, p twiddle squared
plus k over 2.
This is all very tedious,
but the payoff is very soon.
k over 2 times hr mu
omega, x twiddle squared.
Oh, isn't that interesting?
We can combine-- we can
absorb a k over mu in omega,
and so we get, actually,
a big simplification.
We get h bar omega
over 2 times p twiddle
squared plus x twiddle squared.
Well, that looks simpler.
And so the next thing we do is--
it looks like a simple problem
from algebra, let's factor this.
Now, it's a little
tricky because you
know you can factor
something in real terms
if this is a minus sign.
But we are allowed to talk
about complex quantities,
so we can factor that.
And so this term, p twiddle
squared plus x twiddle squared
is equal to ip twiddle, plus x
twiddle times minus ip twiddle,
plus x.
And you can work that out-- that
ip times minus ip is p squared,
and x times x is x squared.
And then we have these
cross-terms, ip times
x and x times minus ip.
Whoops, they don't commute.
If this were algebra--
well, they would go
away, but they don't.
And so what you
end up getting is
p twiddle squared plus x twiddle
squared, plus i times p--
I'm going to stop
writing the twiddles.
So we have this.
I want to make sure that I
haven't sabotaged myself--
that's going to be--
yeah, that's right.
So we have something
here that isn't zero.
And it looks like i times
the commutator of p twiddle
with x twiddle.
But we can work
that out because we
know the commutator of p
ordinary with x ordinary.
And so I did that.
And so we have this commutator,
p twiddle, x twiddle.
After some algebra,
we get plus 1.
A number-- pure number--
no?
I want you to check my algebra.
So you just substitute
in what this
is in terms of ordinary
p and the ordinary x.
Use a commutator for
ordinary xp, which is ih-bar,
and magically, you get plus 1.
So this very strange and
boring derivation says, OK--
well, let's now give
these two things names.
This guy, we're going to call
as the square root of 2 times a,
and this one is going
to be the square root
of 2 times a-dagger.
So H is going to be
h-bar omega over 2,
times square root
of 2a-hat times
the square root of
2a-dagger-hat minus 1.
Remember, when we
factored it, we
got this extra term which was 1.
And in order to make it correct,
we have to subtract it away.
And so this becomes h-bar
omega, a-dagger-hat minus 1/2.
Well, isn't that nice?
Now, we have the Hamiltonian
expressed as a constant, which
we know is important because
it's related to the energy
levels, and times these
two little things,
which turn out to be
the gift from God.
It's an incredible
thing, what these do.
So we have gone
through some algebra,
and we know the relationship
between a, and the x and p
twiddles, and
similarly for a-dagger.
And we can go in
the other direction,
and we know the
commutator, and now we're
going to start doing
some really great stuff.
Well, one thing we're going to
want to know about is a-hat.
a-hat, a-dagger,
that commutator-hat.
And that turns out to be--
well, I already derived it--
it turns out to be plus 1.
And as a result, we can say
things like this-- a a-dagger--
So using this trick, we can show
we can always replace something
like a, a-dagger by a-dagger
a plus this commutator, which
is 1.
And so we have this
really neat way
of reversing the order
of the a's and a-daggers.
So with this, we're
going to soon discover
the a operating on the
eigenfunction gives square root
of v times psi v minus 1.
And a-dagger operating
on this wave function
gives v plus 1 square
root of psi v plus 1.
Which is the reason these
things are valuable,
because if you have
any eigenfunction,
you can get all the others.
So suppose you have the
lowest eigenfunction--
you apply a-dagger
on it as many times
as you need to get
to, say vth function.
So you don't actually--
you're not going to be
evaluating integrals, you're
going to be counting
a's and a-daggers,
and permuting them around,
and getting 1's, and stuff
like that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In this line
with the commutator,
you didn't move the dagger.
ROBERT FIELD: I didn't what?
AUDIENCE: For a, a times the
square root of a a-dagger plus
a-dagger a, it
should be a a-dagger.
And on the right-hand side,
you need to move the dagger.
ROBERT FIELD: OK, so this
is to switch the order,
and I've done that.
And that then is--
no, I think-- wait a second.
So we have a a-dagger--
so that's a a-dagger minus
a-dagger a, and that's--
oh, yeah.
Thank you.
It's very, very easy to get
lost, and once you're lost,
you can never be
found because you've
made a mistake that's
built into your logic,
and you're never
going to see it.
You see it took me a couple
of minutes to even accept--
that the insight from my TA
who's sitting there calmly
thinking, and I'm trying to
do several things in addition
to the thinking.
So we can do things like this.
Suppose we have psi--
I can't use this notation yet.
So suppose we have
psi-star v, and we
have a-dagger, a-dagger,
a-dagger, psi, v prime, dx.
These are raising
operators, so this
is going to take v
prime to v prime plus 3.
That's the only
integral that's not 0.
And we get v prime plus 1, v
prime plus 2, v prime plus 3,
square what?
It has the constants.
And this would be
v prime plus 3.
So instead of
evaluating an integral,
looking at what the
x's and p's are,
we just have a
little game we play.
So now, we have to prove
some of the things I've said.
So we have h, and we're going
to operate on a-dagger psi v.
So what does the Hamiltonian
do to this thing?
So what we're
going to want to do
is to show that this
thing is an eigenvalue--
eigenfunction of v
plus 1, and that's
what we are going to get.
So let's just go through this.
So we have h-bar omega, a-dagger
a plus 1/2, times psi v.
So what I did is--
where did I-- yeah, I showed
that the Hamiltonian--
or did I not do that yet?
Oh, yeah-- I did it right here.
The Hamiltonian is h-bar
omega, a a-dagger minus 1/2,
or if we reverse these, it's
equal to h-bar omega, a-dagger,
a plus 1/2.
So we can use either one,
so I'm using that one--
except I wanted
an a-dagger here,
because we want to show what
the Hamiltonian does to this.
Now, we can pull in a-dagger
out to the right, because this--
if it's 1/2 times a-dagger,
well, that doesn't matter.
This a-dagger, a,
a-dagger-- well,
we can pull this a-dagger out.
So we have h-bar omega, a-dagger
is equal to a a-dagger plus
1/2--
so iv.
Now, we use our magic
commutator trick
to replace this by
a-dagger a plus 1.
So now, we have h-bar
omega, a-dagger,
and we have a-dagger a
plus three halves is iv.
Well, this is Ev
plus h-bar omega.
We've increased the
number that started here.
Here is Ev-- that was Ev plus 1.
And so now, we have
no operators in here,
and we can stick the
a-dagger back here.
And so we have h-bar
omega, Ev plus 1, a-dagger
Well, what do we have here?
We have an operator,
we have this function,
we have some constant
times the same function.
So what we've shown
is that this thing
is an eigenfunction
of the Hamiltonian
that belongs to the
eigenvalue Ev plus 1.
We've increased the energy by 1.
So what we have--
so we can show that
we apply a-dagger
to any function-- we
increase its energy,
and we can do this forever.
We could also do a similar
thing if we apply a to psi v. We
can go down, but at some
point, we run out of steam
because we've gone to the lowest
energy, and if we go lower,
we get 0.
So a operating on
psi min gives 0.
So we have this stack of energy
levels and wave functions,
and we have the same stack
being repeated as we go down,
but this one has an end.
We bring back what a is,
and so a psi min is 0--
that's the equation.
We bring in what a is, and it's
ip twiddle x plus x twiddle.
So we do some algebra,
and what we end up
with is a differential
equation, psi min.
dxx twiddle is equal to--
again, a little
bit more algebra--
minus mu omega over
h-bar times psi min.
So what function gives--
there's an x in here too.
So what function
has a derivative,
which is the function
you had started
with, times the variable,
times a constant?
And so the answer to
that is that psi min
has to have the form--
some normalization factor
times e to the minus m omega--
or mu omega-- sorry--
over 2 h-bar x squared--
a Gaussian.
Well, it had to be
a Gaussian, right?
We know when we did
the algebra that we're
going to get some
function times a Gaussian.
But for the lowest function,
the Hermite polynomial is 1,
and all there is
is the Gaussian.
And so we found the lowest
level, and we can normalize it.
So let's start over here.
So what we have
found is psi min of x
is equal to mu omega over
pi h-bar to the 1/4 power, e
to the minus mu omega
over 2 h-bar squared.
Well, that's useful.
We knew that, but this
time we got it out
of a completely different path.
And now, we can
get all higher v by
a-dagger, a-dagger, et cetera.
So remember, we
don't care anything
about what the
function is, we just
know that we can bring it in
and get rid of it at will,
because what we want is the
values of integrals involving
that function and some operator.
So yeah, we can have
all of those functions,
and this is a way of generating
all of the functions.
And so if we wanted psi v, we
would do a-dagger to the vth
power divided by v-dagger--
v-- what do you call this
with an exclamation point?
Factorial-- ha!
So we apply this operator that
raises us to whatever level
we want starting from this
Gaussian at the bottom,
and we have this normalization
factor which cancels out
the fact the stuff that
you get by applying av.
Now, there is some
more logic in my notes,
and I don't want to
do that, but what
we'd like to be able to show
is that a-dagger on psi v
gives some constant, and
that this constant has
some value-- we're going
to evaluate what it is.
And similarly, a psi v gives dv,
and some constant v minus that.
We can derive those
things, and I'm not going
to waste time deriving them--
I'm going to just
give you the values.
But we already know that cv
is square of v plus 1/2--
e plus 1 and dv--
and you can see the
derivation in my notes.
I don't think going through
them is going to be instructive.
And that's just going
to be v and 1/2.
So now, we have something
that's wonderful,
because everything you need
to know about getting numbers
concerning harmonic oscillator
is obtained from these five
equations.
a-dagger on psi v is v plus
1 square root psi v plus 1.
a on psi v is v square
root psi, v minus 1.
I've said this before, but
these are the most useful things
you'll ever encounter.
We have this thing called
the number operator,
and that number operator
is a-dagger-hat,
and the number operator
operating on psi v
gives v psi v. And so that's
a kind of benign operator
that can suck up all sorts
of factors of a-dagger a,
because it just
gives a useful thing.
And then we have a,
a-dagger, and this is 1.
Well, you sort of
know it's going
to be 1, because a a-dagger
gives an increase-- it gives v
plus 1, and a gives v minus 1.
So it's plus 1, not minus 1--
you know that it's hardwired.
Well, I did it--
I got to the point where it
starts to get interesting.
So we're going to be using
this notation, a-dagger and a,
for all sorts of stuff.
And one sort of thing is
transition intensities
and selection rules.
So you have a
harmonic oscillator.
A harmonic oscillator is,
say a diatomic molecule
which is heteronuclear.
And so as the
molecule vibrates, you
have a dipole moment
which is oscillating.
And so any oscillating
electric field
will grab a hold of
that dipole moment
and stretch or
compress it, especially
if that field is in
resonance with h-bar omega.
And I've got some beautiful
animation showing this,
but we can't do that until we
have time dependent quantum
mechanics.
So we have a time
dependent radiation
field, which is
going to interact
with the dipole associated
with the vibrating molecule,
and it's going to
cause transitions.
And so we can write the
quantum mechanical operator
that causes the transitions--
this is the electric
dipole moment operator--
as a function of coordinate.
And we can do a power
series expansion of this,
and we have--
so we have mu 0--
the constant term--
the first derivative
of the dipole
with respect to x, and the
second derivative of the dipole
with respect to x.
And we have the x cofactor
and the x squared cofactor.
And so this guy doesn't have
any x on it-- it's a constant.
The only integrals involving--
the only integrals are delta v,
v prime following the selection
rule delta v v prime.
So these integrals are 0 unless
v and v prime are the same.
And that says, well,
an isolating field
isn't going to do
anything key to it,
it's just going to leave it
in the same vibration level.
But it might have an
electric Stark effect,
but that's something else.
So this term does nothing as
far as vibration is concerned.
This guy, which is
a plus a-dagger,
has a selection rule, delta
v of plus and minus 1,
and this guy has a
selection rule, delta v
of plus and minus 2 and 0.
So if we're interested
in the intensities
of vibrational
transitions, it says,
well, this is the important
term and it causes transitions,
changing the vibrational
quantum number by one, which
is called the fundamental.
This gives rise to overtones.
So all of a sudden, we're
in real problem land, where
if we're looking at vibrational
transitions in a molecule,
that this enables us to
calculate what's important,
or to say these are the
intensities I measure,
and these are the first
and second derivative
of the dipole moment operator
as a function of internuclear
distance.
Isn't that neat?
I've gone so fast, I'm more or
less at the end of my notes,
but I can blather
on for a while.
So suppose you have
some integral involving
an operator and a
vibrational wave function.
So we have psi v star, some
operator, psi v prime dx.
And we'd like to know how
to focus our energies.
We're very busy people--
we don't want any
value integrals
that come out to be 0,
we'd like to just know.
So if this operator is some
function of x or function of p,
we'd have a power series
expansion of the operator,
and we then know what
the selection rules are.
So usually, you
look at the operator
and you find that it's a linear
quadratic cubic function of x--
the leading term
is usually linear.
Bang-- you have a
delta v of plus 1--
selection rule.
Or if someone has bothered
to actually convert
the operator to some form--
oh, it's the operator--
this might have some
form, a-dagger cubed times
some constant.
So if the operator looks
like a-dagger cubed,
we know that the selection
rule is v to v plus 3,
and we know that the matrix
of the integral is v plus 1,
times v plus 2, times v
plus 3, square root of that,
times the constant.
So there is a huge
number of problems
that, instead of being
pages and pages of algebra,
are just reduced something that
you can tell by inspection.
So one of the tricks
is we have an operator
like x squared or x cubed--
what we want to do is
write this in terms
of a squared, a-dagger
squared, and maybe
some combination of a-dagger a.
So we want to take the a-dagger
a's with the a a-daggers
and combine them using
the commutation rule.
And then we have expressed this
in this maximally simple form,
and then you just
apply a squared,
apply a-dagger squared,
and you apply this,
then you've got the
value of the integral.
So if you're a
busy person and you
want to actually
calculate stuff,
you want to know how
to reduce operators--
usually expressed as some
power of the coordinate
or the momentum--
into a sum of terms
involving these organized
products of a's and a-daggers.
And you're going to be
absolutely shocked at how
perturbation theory--
which leads to basically all of
the formulas and spectroscopy--
it's an ugly theory, but it
reduces everything to things
that you can just write down
at the speed of your pen
or pencil, and that's
a fantastic thing.
So you can't do this with
the particle in a box,
you can't do this
with a hydrogen atom,
with the rigid--
well, you can do some of
this with a rigid rotor.
But the harmonic
oscillator is so ubiquitous
because every
one-dimensional problem
is harmonic at the bottom.
And so you can use it and then
you can put in the corrections.
But also because you want
to describe dynamics,
you almost always use
the harmonic oscillator,
because not only do
you know the integrals,
but you know there's only a few.
Normally, you're
going to be summing
over an infinite number
of quantum numbers,
and that takes time, and
it takes judgment to say,
well, only certain of
these are important.
But for the harmonic
oscillator, the sums are finite.
All of these things
are wonderful,
and that's why whenever
you look at a theory,
you're going to discover
that hidden in there
is the harmonic
oscillator approximation,
because everything is
doable in no effort.
And sometimes when you
look at a paper like that,
it doesn't show you
the intermediate steps,
because everybody knows what
a harmonic oscillator does.
And there's also
a lot of insight
because something like this--
this is an odd symmetry term,
this is an even symmetry term,
and there are all sorts of
things that have to do with,
are you're conserving
symmetry or changing symmetry?
And sometimes, the issue is how
does the molecule spontaneously
change symmetry
by doing something
interacting with a
field, or interacting
with some feature of
the potential surface.
So this is a place where
it's labor saving and insight
generating, and
it's really amazing.
So maybe I've bored
you with this,
but this is the beginning
of almost every theory
that you encounter just because
of the simplicity of the a's
and a-daggers.
OK, I'm done.
Thank you.